non moi je m'excuse mais je suis obligé
de dénoncer un scanner jeudi que les
moyens qui sont mis à l'état à la
disposition de monsieur claude françois
c'est monstrueux par rapport que ça
coûterait moins cher
s'il y avait moins de moyens c'est ça
qui va éclairer les travailleurs et les
masses populaires la télévision coûtent
trop cher aux travailleurs
moi je dis qu'au lieu de faire une
télévision nationale qui coûte trop cher
à payer aux travailleurs et aux masses
populaires
on devrait faire une télévision
régionale dans une seule région
ma région la normandie parce qu'il ya
que deux personnalités qui intéresse les
travailleurs dans notre pays c'est moi
le normand de la politique et lui gérard
lenorman de la chanson